[Musique]
christian baptisto enfin je suis
retraité et puis bon bain artistes
chanteurs et puis aussi membre de
l'association les showcases présidée par
mon épouse huguette baptiste haut depuis
décembre 95 avait un copain qui
s'appelait lui jean-paul home avait 16
ans et puis marseillais qui jouait dans
un orchestre qui s'appelait les
aventuriers mais combien tu voyais que
méchante et puis mes bijoux et le type
et de la guitare
donc mon 1er au 15 c'était dans les
aventuriers en 1966 à peu près moi je
vais dans les keys avec celle alba que
le mari de biche oh moi là je vais aussi
beaucoup dans le club rythmique avec
puisse adélaïde fred espel et plumages
encore déguisé dorcas puis ça pas inhumé
à parce qu'il n'a que deux militants et
entre temps en 76 on l'a fait mon
premier 45 tours
bell a eu 8 ou 10 45 tours et puis
d'essayer jusqu'aujourd'hui moi
travailler avec palmes osaka et est
ensuite catherine chacune à la direction
de la culture avec paul et puis il y
avait aussi gilbert pounia l'époque
jacqueline farreyrol nous l'a lancé
l'opération d'espèces physique en 90
donc encore à 11,9 et le festival au
théâtre de saint gilles avec les étoiles
quatre heures que l'a reçue et ankama 13
c'est de là qu'il a démarré la fabuleuse
carrière de barbelés en 295 avec mon
épouse huguette nous a décidé de faire
l'ascension des chocas les accessions la
musique la musique la préservation de
notre patrimoine immatériel musicale il
ne l'a fait un festival eau terre des
syndics sa place je laisse les ja qui a
commencé en 2003 que la terminer en 2017
et apprennent la fibre ball stars aussi
à pâtir 2017 pour le festival des
seniors les grands de la musique
réunionnaise
en parallèle ne l'a pas pour la
sauvegarde du patrimoine nous l'a fait
les cds de bananes à peu près une
dizaine
ne commencez pas aux bobos maloya c'est
une anthologie sur le maloya dans la
donne à un livret de 40 pages qui
raconte l'histoire du maloya et même en
2018 ne l'a fait un catalogue que damian
valu 25 artistes et cette année nous
refait un autre sur 25 autres en plus et
ben moi je pense que le trait dominant
ben c'est l'amour quoi pour faire ce que
mon épouse et moi il fait il faut avoir
beaucoup d'amour pour son prochain
1 parce que nous gagne 0 fonda dans un
message on nous fait parce que nous y
sommes enfin parce que l'amour tout
simplement
il faut pas que n'oublie nous de passer
donc donc il faut toujours que dana
cette préservation là cette préservation
du patrimoine
et puis aussi un engagement que ce soit
de côté associatif ou même d'aider des
côtes et politique et aussi ben merci à
mon épouse parce que des abris
un joli moon et puis et puis et puis il
ya deux mois hahaha